hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream q a 94 ready to go
locked and loaded
all right i was trying it out i don't
think it was right it didn't feel right
but
at least now we know now we know now we
know
question number one
just today i was accepted into a phd
program to develop my thoughts about
belief systems and how beliefs evolve
how the meme evolves analogously to the
gene and the interplay of gene and meme
i recently wrote an article about
political beliefs and i appreciate any
comments about if you have time to read
it also thank you both for being
critical reasonable voices and time of
increasing madness
uh so i for it's hard to click on things
with our new system so it took me a
little while and i haven't uh i haven't
spent any time with it but um
i will we will try to take a quick look
at this
it sounds like a fascinating phd program
and i'm curious what um you know what
the department is
could you describe the uh the program
again i to develop i've been accepted
into a phd program to develop my
thoughts about belief systems and how
beliefs evolve how the meme evolves
analogously to the gene and the
interplay of gene and meme
so um
you know one thing you'll be interested
in is the omega principle which we've
talked about and which we introduced
formally in the first i think chapter of
our book
which will be out in a couple weeks
couple plus weeks
um
and so that um that provides a
theoretical underpinning an introduction
to a theoretical underpinning for why
there is um you know really more than
analogy between me and gene
yes an obligate relationship
yeah
so anyway yes i'll be very interested to
see how that develops did
okay next question
do we know exactly how long we have
natural immunity after exposure to the
coronavirus if you receive one of the
vaccines during that period of immunity
can the vaccine interfere with our
immune system so that's two different
questions do we know exactly how long we
have natural immunity after exposure to
the coronavirus and we've talked about a
couple of um papers on here um
one of which found eight months
but that it wasn't that after eight
months immunity starts to wane it was
that that was the point at which they
stopped collecting the data that was
when um it was time to do the analysis
and publish um so at least eight months
and really longer term than that we just
don't have any evidence yeah we don't
know that it fails at any particular
moment and um
and at least eight months and it may
never right lifelong immunity is
definitely on the table of possibilities
here and that that really comes in two
flavors right there's lifelong immunity
were we doing nothing that interfered
with the virus and its evolution and
there's lifelong
um
immunity that might not be lifelong in
light of what we drive the virus to
become and so depending on how strong
selective pressures are on the virus if
we change it so much that natural
immunity gotten to an earlier covid may
not be good against a later code right
but here's the good news the good news
is that driving the adaptive evolution
of covid with very narrow vaccines
is liable not to change the majority of
the genome right to the extent of the
genome of the virus right we are
applying
pressure with respect to the spike
protein and because we are applying
pressure with respect to the spike
protein we should expect rapid evolution
of the spike protein
genes
but that leaves the rest intact so to
the extent that there is much better
immunity coming from a natural encounter
with covid than we get from vaccines
it is also liable to be durable even in
light of the evolution that we are
driving because that evolution is
narrowly focused so
um i guess i would say so far the
indications are quite good on natural
immunity it is both broad and long
lasting yeah
and the second part of that question was
um
if you receive one of the vaccines
during that period of immunity having
had coveted and recovered can the
vaccine interfere with our immune system
i would say other than the possibility
of ade there's no reason to think this
wow i want to be real careful not to
make too many assumptions here because
for one thing there are
if you've had covid
and you get vaccinated
and the vaccine is taken up by your
cells as it will be and starts
transcribing spike protein
that is liable to trigger a fraction of
the immunity from the initial
covid so it's the immune response the
immune response so it interacts but you
know i think the bottom line is the
systems in question are so complex that
it is impossible to rule anything out on
principle the question is whether or not
one should expect
um expect such a thing and
and even i mean the situation that you
describe
is not the vaccine interfering with the
immune system it's the immune system
kicking into gear and responding to the
expected and
desirable effects of the vaccine and
thus maybe making the vaccines effect
somewhat less strong than they would be
absent the natural immunity because
you've already got the natural immunity
on board well yes but there's also
funny possibilities um so
to the extent that a person has immunity
from
has natural immunity from an encounter
with the virus some of that natural
immunity is liable to target the spike
proteins if you then produce the spike
proteins themselves as the vaccines will
induce a person to do then the immunity
that one has developed to coronavirus
spike proteins will presumably attach to
the spike proteins produced by the
vaccine effect so that could decrease
immunity somewhat because it is
occupying
antibodies that would naturally
contribute to resistance to a next
encounter with the virus might make you
even particularly susceptible in that
inter in that early
uh period
right except for i would say if i had to
predict i would say the chances of that
being a significant effect are low
because even if those antibodies that
you generate to the spike protein are
occupied by this encounter with the
vaccines the fact that you will have
reacted to other antigens means it's not
your only defense so my guess is if you
measure finely enough you'll see it but
that it may not be a big effect
good
yeah
um and i always forget because it's not
because i'm not doing it the same way
that we have a question from discord
this week
let's see if i can pull it up
um why
let me ask another question have you
answer it and then i'll pull it up since
my phone is not playing with me
um
let's just pick this up since it's
relevant to the one we just answered
excuse me
if understanding of ade
that is antibody dependent enhancement
in sars and stars 1 and mers infections
has taken several years
why is the medical community so
confident that because ade hasn't been
observed yet in cysco v2 that it won't
be a factor the argument seems to be
that we would have seen ade by now but
aren't we potentially only a mutation
away from the risk of ade
yes i think we don't know much about
this at all especially
in light of the fact that waning
immunity
is
liable
if ade is a factor waning immunity will
be a contributing uh
causal um i'm looking for an alternative
to the word factor component
um
but
uh let's put it this way there is no
basis for confidence that ade is not
involved
one can say we haven't seen the signal
yet that's debatable but it is at least
a plausible position at the moment but
nobody can say we won't see it right
i think there is a rush
to consensus around the safety and
wisdom of our current vaccine-based plan
that causes people to say well
what answer would be desirable if we
wanted to reassure people about this
plan
what would the answer have to be and so
basically all of the
things that would lead to greater
confidence that this was in fact the
right plan rather than a big mistake or
an inadequate plan all of those things
are being embraced with the idea that um
that they will pull uh tony fauci later
and say well the evidence changed on us
rather than actually a wise person would
have thought to worry about this right
exactly
okay um
discord question for this week i found
both the discord question and this fine
cat
wow
well you're answering that question
um
he's sucking out
all the light out of the room yes he
definitely absorbs light
um
how do we decide on which changes to
make if any in systems that are
sufficiently complex there appears to be
a real risk of decision paralysis when
applying chesterton's fence too strictly
that's from the discord service yeah
that's an interesting interesting
question i would say look ideally
speaking
the fact that a system is complex
doesn't mean if you had infinite room or
infinite uh iterations of a system you
could change one parameter at a time and
measure the implications the problem is
when a system is one that you are
depending on a system that you are
actively
using you can't necessarily afford to
wait and so there ought to be a bias in
terms of
minimizing change right only changes
that are
really necessary frankly uh as exists in
our hanukkah tradition
the reversibility of any change
has to be built in because to the extent
that you can be surprised by something
you didn't think to predict
undoing
is is the key mechanism for rescuing the
system from whatever change you've made
but the other answer to this is
and you know in the book we talk about
effectively navigating to a new and
better more functional system that
accomplishes more of the things that we
uh believe we want
than the system that we currently have
rather than blueprinting that system
but the point is
that a properly built system is built so
that it becomes antifragile right and
anti-fragility for those of you who
aren't deeply familiar with the concept
is a naseem tele idea and the idea is
systems that
become stronger when they are pushed
around are anti-fragile systems that
break down when they
are confronted with challenge are
fragile and to the extent that your
system is well built as our
physiological systems are very well
built perturbations do not cause them to
break down right so what you want is a
system that when you make an error is
actually robust to that error and allows
you to backtrack what we have is a
system in which because everything is
new and these things are combining in
ways that we don't understand i mean
what happens
you know when you have
democracy
interacting with
an internet that allows
all kinds of new interactions huge
degrees of anonymity the
discontinuity of where people are in
space as they talk to each other we
don't know what the impacts of these
things are
and so anyway we have a system that is
inherently fragile by the virtue of the
fact that it is highly complex and
highly novel that is to say not only
have many of the pieces not stood the
test of time but their interactions have
not stood the test of time and so we
constantly get surprised by
things that
we thought were safe that turn out not
to be for example
so the basic idea would be you want a
system that builds up out of
robust
parts
so that at the point that you do make an
error it becomes clear that you've made
an error and so you can undo that piece
and continue on
great
this next question
empiricism is really an experience but
99 of people are outsourcing experience
to institutions their knowledge is
rooted in trust what do we do when the
trust is gone
um
you know
the matrix is a compromised film because
it was generated in part uh as an
artistic expression and in part as a
an exploitation of a market opportunity
but it does have a lot of elements in it
that are
useful the idea that one does not unplug
somebody from the matrix after a certain
age because they can't handle it
is resonant there's a degree to which
you can get pretty far especially in a
system that's humming along a highly
productive system
if you
place your trust in things that you know
rule of thumb seem to work
you know you can go lifetime that way if
you're lucky if you live in the right
era and the more complex the system the
more you have to do that de facto for
some number of things or else you're
just mired in decision paralysis right
exactly it's very hard when you're
navigating everything all a cart but you
know if you know in the 50s if you
signed up with the right company
um you know
it might be a good deal it might be a
bad deal but the chances that it was
going to carry you through your career
and put a roof over your head and pay
for your medical care and all that was
pretty high
what we've got now is a system in which
trust is almost always misplaced in
institutions because all of the
institutions have been captured and
corrupted
and so in some sense we're
we are watching a population lash about
as a response to the fact that trust is
constantly being breached right it's
it's you know being told otherwise it's
being told that you're being taken care
of and that those people are the enemy
but in fact what people are discovering
is you can't trust any of this stuff
because
of you know because the system is rigged
in favor of things that not only
aren't
about you but they're also not wise they
don't protect these structures they
don't protect the things that keep us
safe
they can in fact steer us directly into
danger so
the basic problem is
people are beginning to discover that
their trust has been misplaced they
don't know what to do with the fact that
they need to trust something and many do
not have the tools to substitute for
institutions that are trustworthy you
know first principle
reasoning
sounds great but most people
don't it's not something you can start
late in life right and even people who
are good at it within a particular realm
are often not good at it across a wide
breadth of topics so
you know we we've got a problem and
really you know if we're to get through
this
the key is going to be replacing those
institutions with something that can be
trusted and
relate in starting that project yeah we
are late
but it's only getting later
yes it's later than we think
which federal government institutions do
you believe are captured and no longer
functioning i would put the cdc fdi fdi
i would put the cdc fda and fbi at the
top of the list much love for you guys
i'm trying to think of the ones
that are meaningfully not captured yeah
i think that's going to be an easier
it's going to be a shorter list um
unfortunately um
well and i guess that's not entirely
fair necessarily captured and no longer
functioning is
definitely an overlapping uh category
categorization scheme but it's not
totally overlapping those are two
different different things um
captured
means inherently no longer functioning
with the goal that it was established to
do
but no longer function can happen a
number of different ways beyond um
beyond being captured
um
you know what what does work what
federal government institutions are
working at this point
um
well the post office had a rough time of
it there but it seems to be kind of
functional
yeah i mean
we've been making this point for for
decades now but you know the the post
office as bad as it is is is a
you know an amazingly
functional system the fact that you can
i don't exactly know what the price of a
stamp is these days because they don't
have the numbers on them anymore i don't
either but i don't know 49 cents right
but for something less than a buck the
fact that you can uh get a
a document across the country in a
couple of days it's incredible it's
incredible yeah it's totally incredible
and you know the attack that has always
uh
leveled against it that it's not
profitable it's not supposed to be yeah
the military is also not profitable
right lots of things aren't supposed to
be that's not their purpose right right
um you know i guess because it looks
like a business because you walk through
a door you interact with somebody who
seems like a retail employee in some
ways and they may charge you for a
service it feels like a business but
yeah but it's not it's not that whereas
you know i'm thinking of like
the nsf
znih
the nea which is which is different but
in the same vein you know the national
endowment for the arts the national
institutes for health and its sub
sub things and national um science
foundation
all seem pretty broken i know the least
about the nea at this point there was a
while there where i was i was actively
thinking about them it's been it's been
years um but you know they seem to be
broken by some different different
captures um
but the nsf and nih are just um
it's it's market forces and perverse
incentives all the way down yeah and i i
think what what you hear is us
struggling with the fact that we pretty
much know the answer to the question is
the whole thing has been captured it's
and you know for different purposes some
of them i think truly nefarious some of
them mundane but
the
the basic point is because we weren't
minding the store and because there's a
tremendous amount at stake in any
federal project at least from the point
of view of
um you know
simple
you know the profit that can be made by
simply corrupting an institution pretty
much the whole thing has been yeah has
been captured this is not this is not
answer to the question but one thing
that it occurs to me is i'm remembering
uh when we were living in washington and
teaching at evergreen we often had
students who either went into
either summer internships or after
graduating went into jobs um with with
the state in part olympia which is where
evergreen was also the state capital
capital it's not a word no south korea
it's not even a thing no but it's also
the state capital and therefore where
the various state agencies are and um
given what i was tending to teach anyway
i had a lot of students sort of you know
eco-crunchy students you know students
interested in
being in wilderness preserving wildness
preserving habitat
and it would have seemed like okay well
they're probably going to go into the
department of fish and wildlife or the
doe department of ecology
and for reasons having to do with
you know mostly i think not capture and
mostly not even incompetent bureaucratic
incompetence although there's certainly
some of that everywhere there's
bureaucracy
some of the really most interesting uh
work on preserving wildlands and um
doing mitigation stuff was in the dot
the state dot the department of
transportation and so you had these you
know really capable and amazing
scientists working with the department
of transportation and a lot of the work
going on at department of ecology was of
no interest whatsoever and so you know
this this always struck me as sort of
unfortunately a perfect a perfect
version of you don't know where where
you might land that you could end up
doing powerful and important work and
unfortunately the
uh constraints of the system that you're
in are going to be big in deciding that
and so you know the name the name over
the door doesn't tell you much
all right i'm going to eat these words
okay um
will they satisfy you when you do no no
no
i will not enjoy eating them um the faa
i'm going to say if something stands a
really good chance of not having been
captured it's going to be the faa and
the reason is because
planes aren't falling out of the sky now
it may be that it's captured and that
the thing that captured it has an
interest in planes it's not falling out
of the sky
don't know but or the the reveal on it
being captured would be so obvious it's
so immediate that although obviously
they think the core competency just has
to remain right has to remain um
okay okay yeah i know i think i mean
this could be this could be fun um
to work to work on i feel like there's
got to be more and we're missing it and
hopefully the people who work in those
in those places and others
who don't will
will write in or something and tell us
what parts of the federal government or
state governments are truly functional
so i think the era
in which we recapture government and
again serves the interests of the public
should be heralded by the change of the
name of the department of fish and
wildlife to the department of fish and
other wildlife i would take that as a
very positive sign that adults had again
taken charge adults who had maybe taken
some biology
paid attention you know i actually don't
even i i've sort of given up on that one
it's it's when people invoke animals and
birds and birds yeah that really gets
under my skin yeah no there's no there's
luckily there's no federal department of
animals and birds
yet
[Laughter]
yeah yes right yeah okay they're
definitely
not doing what most people want us to do
no we are
[Laughter]
in trouble
that's that's i think people do kind of
want us to do that but we don't cause
trouble for the sake of causing trouble
do we no no um
we just we
we have long argued for full wildlife
status of fish
um
and full animal status of birds right
and um for the full fish status of
tetrapods so anyway that tells you who
you're dealing with
yeah
interested in truth even at the expense
of
um comprehensibility right there it is
right
okay uh meanwhile tesla our cat is
looking at me like get on with it guys
just get to the next question
all right
sharing a critical realism lens of
reality critical realism lens of reality
is what unites traditional secular
liberals like you with religious
conservatives like me
when i converse philosophically with my
teenagers secular friends i explain with
examples that they are living through a
cultural shift that affirms a subjective
reality
yeah i do i i've never heard it called
that critical realism um but i i think
this is exactly right and you know part
of why i shared
some of the conversation that i had with
this this lovely woman that i met today
um you know she's she's not a
conservative but she's religious um and
you know a religious
uh a woman of deep faith um who is also
a liberal is is also you know is is yet
a third category here and there are
there are plenty more right but
certainly
um
you know
traditional secular liberals and
religious conservatives
um both see a
value in and in effect a need to
discuss reality as it presents itself as
opposed to reality um only in the terms
of how it makes people feel
there's something i don't there's
probably a principle here i don't know
the name of it
but
there's something about the basic
capacity to do a certain kind of
thinking
that has nothing to do with what happens
as you get to
the
um super remote foundation of the thing
right so
i think it's always been true
that
great teachers
are people who have that capacity at the
point that they mature into a role where
they can teach rather than people who
did really well in teaching school right
right that's not where you pick it up
great psychologists to the extent that
they exist are not people who did really
well in graduate school and really
understood the lesson these are people
who have a deep intuitive understanding
of what makes people tick and you know
what ways they mislead themselves and
those sorts of things right manual
therapists the same way so you know
people who are excellent in physical
therapy or massage or strain counter
strain therapy or any of these manual
therapies like you
you it's best if you know the science
but you also need to have the hands and
um you can't really learn that right
or you don't i think the point is if you
take any of these you know great
teachers great psychologists people who
manipulate the body to um to positive
effect and you keep asking
well why is it that way why is it that
way eventually you get to some layer
where they're probably going to say
something that isn't
defensible right and the point is well
it didn't really matter because you were
asking them to do something
founded in something that they didn't
know really well right
and
uh so the point is
i actually i just think the difficulty
in
reasoning with people who come from a
very different perspective like a
religious perspective if you sit down
next to somebody right and they impress
you as intelligent and insightful and
you know careful then
at the point you discover that they come
from a religious grounding that believes
that all of this was set in motion by
somebody who wanted it this way
how much does that actually impact right
as long as at the point that they get to
what one actually does with the stuff
and how one understands
uh the facts of of reality as they
present themselves
you know the point is oh it's
interesting that you come from a very
different perspective you know just as
you could
you know how much does it matter if your
neurosurgeon uh believes in pan psychism
right i happen to think pan psychism is
a nonsense idea yes
psychism is the idea that consciousness
came before matter in the evolution yeah
but it's deeply written into the matter
at the level of particles or something
like this i think this is a completely
indefensible idea that buys you
absolutely nothing in terms of what it
explains there's nothing operational
there there's nothing you're neuro your
narrow what do you say neuroscientist
you're a neurosurgeon or a surgeon a
neurosurgeon can do right to
operationalize that crazy belief such
that you are then affected by it right
exactly and so i think that this is
actually you know and i will say we know
some very smart people who uh believe in
pan psychism right and the point is yep
you can predict if that's where dinner
table conversation goes we're gonna have
an argument right but if that's not
where dinner table conversation goes it
doesn't get in the way that much and
frankly this is the case you know i
think it is especially true for
scientific people of a scientific
materialist worldview like us
you know we know
that there is
uh a place where the models that we are
depending on get ever more
metaphorical because we just don't have
the information about how it works yet
right right we haven't figured it out
and so the point is oh it doesn't make
me uncomfortable right you can call
those you know you can call that faith
or you can say it's a placeholder for a
you know a theory we don't yet have
um but it's you know
as long as you're sort of aware that
there's a vagueness in your own
understanding if there's a you know
a humility to your intellectual
framework such that it can accept that
yeah some of it's actually more literal
than others then the point is you can
get along with pretty much anybody who's
fundamentally reasonable and we should
stop drawing lines
that prevent us from talking to such
folks absolutely
next question
is there any evolutionary advantage to
not fitting in to where you were born uh
and then he says parentheses for
instance having wanderlust
um
those are two different questions i
think so too yeah yeah yeah it's there's
a parenthetical with ie and i think now
it's it's different
uh two different questions yeah so the
wanderlust one is easy right all of us
are descended from people who found some
place that wasn't known before who had
some version of wanderlust you know in
general and so and some
most adventurers fail
um but we are all the descendants of
some successful adventurer explorer yeah
it's an expected value calculation the
fact that you know 99 and 100 such
people may fail and leave no descendants
if you know the one leaves you know
ten thousand times as many uh great
great great grand offspring as they
otherwise would have because they found
a new continent i think we ended up
taking almost all the salmon stuff out
of the book um much to my chagrin um but
you know you you for many many years and
then we wrote into the book this this
discussion of what you know the
ankarinkus the pacific the genus of
pacific salmon
that includes coho and
um sockeye and silver salmon and silver
yeah pink
king
um or anadromous
and um
and symbol paris so anadromous meaning
they are born in fresh water they go out
to the oceans as as very young fish and
they spend their adulthood there and
then they return to their natal streams
in order to reproduce and similar paris
means they they mate once and die
and so at the point that they are
actually returning to their natal
streams uh as they transition from the
salt water back to the fresh water their
their anatomy and physiology changes so
that they can make this last journey but
they actually stop eating and they
basically start digesting themselves
so these they're very extraordinary fish
that we have you know that are all over
the pacific rim i think yeah um but
definitely you know the pacific
northwest and you know very few now down
in california because we've just we've
destroyed the rivers
um
but
you know what what you have talked about
a lot is you know how how is it that
um there isn't just one river with
salmon in it well right like how you
know how how is it that you know as as
extraordinary as symbol parity is that
is to say mating once and then dying as
opposed to iterate parity in which you
have more opportunities for reproductive
success later on which is true for the
vast majority of species including us of
course regardless of whether or not you
actually only do it once we are an
iteroperis species and anatomy this
ability to move from freshwater into
salt water and being mandated there and
then moving back
really complex metabolically and
physiologically
but you know even more
just as extraordinary i would say is how
do they diversify given that if you go
up the wrong stream and you're the only
one who did so then you're guaranteed to
have been a genetic dead end you didn't
you know you don't run into any of your
kind because you went up some wrong
stream so
so
what we have is uh animals that make
what we wrongly understand to be
mistakes in both space and time right a
certain number of fish end up in the
wrong
watershed
hey zach um
[Music]
certain number fish end up at the wrong
watershed and a certain number of fish
come back a year early
and the point is that means that if you
imagine that there's an undiscovered
watershed right one that has no salmon
in it but that could support them it
gets discovered if a
watershed has lost
a salmon run
due to a landslide or something like
that then it gets recolonized and so the
point is it's always it's always been a
logical error to regard these as
mistakes rather than gambles right
that's exactly examine the gamble on uh
the wrong gear or the wrong watershed um
has a very high likelihood of failure
and a very low chance of a very extreme
payoff
um so anyway yeah and so anyway that's
the wanderlust part of the question and
the other part of the question is there
any evolutionary advantage to not
fitting into where you were born
uh
so i mean of course it's funny you know
of course we went to say i did went to
salmon and anatomy and that's an obvious
way to split up these two questions they
could be the same thing but they aren't
inherently and certainly if you're sam
and they're not the same thing right
i would just say
there even they're even two questions in
your not fitting in component here one
is
does selection generate people who don't
fit in because it makes sense to have
such people yeah and i would say
actually left-handedness that's exactly
where i was going to go is is one of
these we know this is not an accident
this is something at low but not zero
frequency and there's roughly 10 across
all cultures right and uh we can make
arguments and that number stands unlike
the number for homosexuality which has
been evoked for so many decades
well let's put it this way there is a
frequency of homosexuality that appears
to be
uh
not stable but there's always some
frequency and so no
absolutely i was gonna say 100 that's
just going to be confusing but um that
10 number has been trotted out for
decades as like yep left lefties are
about 10 of every population every
culture now and homosexuals are about 10
and the number for homosexuals it seems
is probably a lot lower than that always
present but lower whereas
left-handedness um seems to show up at
about 10 percent um across cultures in
cultures that don't mind it and cultures
that uh demonize it you know just
regardless it's it it shows up right so
anyway i would argue both of these
things are
instance oh also colorblindness all of
these things are uh
probably understood best at lineage
level right where the idea is you
you it's not that the left-hander is
that advantage it's that the lineage
that contains the left-handers the
lineage that contains gay people the
lineage that contains colorblind people
at some rate has an advantage over a
lineage that simply doesn't so
those would be simple cases then there's
the other case which is
what happens if
normal is disrupted by something in your
developmental environment is there an
advantage to uh the kind of misfit that
you become when your developmental
environment just went haywire or
something was off right and i would
argue that this too
that basically there is a contingency
program or a set of contingency programs
that takes frankly many of the people
that we revere
right are built of this stuff they had
some experience
that caused them not to see things in
exactly the same way as the people who
had the more normal uh develop
developmental period and then the point
is actually they're in a really good
position to see things that we can't see
and they tell us these things and it
becomes you know it's passed on in you
know in art or something or you know
obviously you could divide that up much
more finely
but basically they have insight that
comes from having traversed some other
route to get here and
you know yes
uh
selection very
rarely
gives up on
creatures it's not wired to do that
because it always makes sense to the
extent you've got a creature what's the
most you can make of this and sometimes
what you make of it is very positive
very good
next question
did evolution select for delusion over
scientific honesty because of the
resulting strength of will and its
advantages for survival and or
domination
thank you both stay the course
um yeah it definitely selects for
delusion for many reasons
you could argue that self-deception is
delusion for the purpose of misleading
others right mislead yourself first and
then mislead others as bob trevors has
explicitly argued yep
you could argue that long odds
could be very demoralizing and that
actually this goes right back to the
question of explorers
um
if you know if somebody was there to
explain to a salmon do you realize how
unlikely it is that you're going to find
a river that doesn't have any salmon in
it and that there will be somebody there
for you to mate with and that you're
going to have lots and lots of offspring
and if the salmon had enough receptive
language to understand what was being
done you'd really have to understand
more than your average salmon but sure
um but anyway the point is uh
what causes you know that was too much
just like i'm out of here talking
salmonella looking for an empty
watershed but um
but
you know i i've made the argument with
respect to people who
in the age of exploration used to get in
onto ships and sail over the horizon
right sailing over the horizon is a very
perilous business right
so
if the expected value of sailing over
the horizon is positive because who
knows you might find a continent nobody
knows about right
but the chances that you as an
individual are going to do anything
other than you know suffer from
scurvy because
the oranges have run out on the ship or
whatever yeah die a scurvy death out at
sea right you're very likely to die an
unpleasant death if your choice is hey
you know i wonder what's over that
horizon
but the point is you should be
because expected value is what selection
is going to care about you should be
inclined to do it then the point is
maybe the story you tell yourself is you
know
i feel lucky about going over that
horizon i think i think this might work
out you know yeah i got a good feeling
about this right i got a good feeling
about this might be [ __ ] most of the
time um but the point is the person who
does find the continent that nobody
knows about probably said it and
actually you know what i have a great
example for this yeah so the you know
the beringians were doing that as they
were heading east from asia
and ultimately into discovering the new
world
i got a good feeling about this and they
didn't have to risk
scurvy in the same way that people on
ships did although i'm honestly not sure
what they did about vitamin c
right
lichen i don't know i don't know what
they're eating they got them to vitamin
c i don't know
maybe
uh contain in certain kinds of
fish meat of some kind
but
anyway um the example i wanted to use
i've always wanted to run an experiment
where we test to see what fraction
of uh lottery winners
have a system for picking numbers my
guess is the answer would be very high
right not because a system works but
because if you believe that you have a
system you're likely to buy lottery
tickets because you think actually i
have a good feeling about this yeah um
so the belief is correlated with buying
a lot of lottery tickets and buying a
lot of lottery tickets is correlated
with having a greater chance of winning
right a greater chance which is still
the expected value is negative in that
case but um nonetheless
from the point of view of who will have
beaten the odds and won the lottery it
will be people who thought they had a
good chance of winning the lottery and
turn out to have been right for the
wrong reasons right exactly
um
regarding
uh creating classroom magic online what
if you did zoom calls but included
audience response and participation in
videos with multiple
seasons
like uh jordan peterson's playlists not
just a straight lecture
there's something interesting there oh
you mean record a zoom call and then put
it up for people who weren't present is
that the idea i think and maybe you know
coming back with uh you know
with engagement with response more times
than once
yeah yeah i think there's something
potentially valuable there um
i must say i feel
even more than i did 18 months ago and i
was already very very much in this camp
that uh i really
i really want physical embodied shared
space with with with people and i think
that would be useful and obviously we're
doing that to some degree here
now um but uh
to some degree my resistance
at the moment that seems to be growing
to sort of online courses is
if i were going to do that sort of thing
i would so very much want it to be in
person
yeah but recognizing that you know we
have we have audience all over the world
and there are a lot of people who would
never ever be able to be in the same
place as we are unless we found
ourselves where they are so
there are
there are
pros and cons of each of the approaches
that we have talked about but that's an
interesting one
heather and brett my doctor is an md phd
who i trust nearly as much as you two
he called ivermectin a quote very dirty
drug end quote with dangerous effects on
the liver and kidneys could you react
um
you know it's possible he knows
something that we don't on the other
hand i will say the safety of ivermectin
does not seem to be something that is
widely disputed amongst people who have
actually looked at it i would i would
say i mean there's there's plenty of
references
i've never seen that and i've now read a
lot of the literature and um the paper
that i showed briefly in the first hour
that we'll link to in the show notes
uh is a really good systematic review of
what ivermectin is known to be effective
in treating
and i guess that you know as an mdphd
who was not just smart but also educated
um you know having a having a systematic
review published in a reputable journal
that says you know here is all of the
ways this has been effective
might be um
might be a good way to
resume a conversation there's that and i
also believe in our sub stack piece on
your sub stack we
linked to a review on the safety
itself yep the safety profile and so i
did not like we did not
separate i was thinking of making a
different post that just had all the
references and
i have that and um but you know they're
all hot linked and so it's not sort of
standard scientific uh protocol but
they're all hot linked in the
appropriate place in the piece you might
you might also ask
this person
what it is that they are referring to
and i don't mean to impugn the
credibility of this person but
one thing that is generally true
is it is pretty safe to say
a medication has an impact on the liver
and
no doubt that exists for iberomectin too
but the question is is it a severe
impact some drugs have a much more
severe impact than you would expect like
tylenol
is very dangerous to the liver
especially if consumed with alcohol yeah
um so people see it as a safe drug
because it's so common but in fact it
has this hazard but i guess the question
is is this person referring to evidence
about liver toxicity is that evidence
robust or is this person guessing about
liver toxicity because if you push the
drug far enough that's what you'll find
and i will say that there's been you
know in the review that discusses the
toxicity question is the fact that
people
it's especially easy in fact to make an
error in dosage based on getting the
decimal point in the wrong place that
can cause an error of a factor of 10
right easily
and so the point is those things have
happened people have overdosed
themselves to a factor of 10. the
question is what happened and i believe
uh the reviews suggest that that has um
not caused serious harm
so does that mean you know
does that mean an error of a factor of
100 wouldn't cause serious arm no almost
certainly it would and we don't know
about long-term implications just as we
discussed in the first hour you know
vitamin you take too much vitamin d
and you're going to have a problem
certainly um
you know i i've seen a lot more evidence
in the in the scientific literature that
tylenol is dangerous at almost any dose
than that ivermectin is yeah um i don't
hear anyone using language like tylenol
is a quote very dirty drug
so that suggests a um
that suggests that something else is
going on
to be using that kind of language here
for a drug with
decades and billion decades of use in
billions of doses yeah i think it's
billions of dollars it is four billion
it's been in human prescribed four
billion times in in humans as far as we
know um i would also say the word dirty
is prejudicial it does sort of have a
disgust uh triggers the disgust circuits
right um so i wonder about i will also
just say uh as much as tylenol is a
suspect drug because of the liver damage
it is also
knowledge that can be useful because to
the extent that tylenol is destructive
of the liver it is actually quite safe
with respect to other things right um
heart damage yeah nsaids for example do
heart damage yeah and the fact is damage
to your liver isn't good but if there's
one tissue where you can afford some
damage yeah right you can afford liver
damage yeah so make it good but yeah
tylenol tylenol use in alcoholics is you
know may shorten their lives quite a lot
uh if you feel the need to take tylenol
don't drink that day or you know i don't
know i don't know how far out it goes
like i've never i you know neither of us
take hardly any of these things and so
haven't had to sort of figure out what
feels safe but certainly not the same
day right like don't do not drink on the
same day that you take tylenol right and
there are cases in which people have um
taken
uh
too much tylenol consistently over a
comparatively brief period of time and
done critical heart uh liver damage so
it's something to be very careful about
and other damage like hearing loss yeah
so uh actually hearing loss from tylenol
itself
i believe so but i'm not certain of that
um anyway what i would say is
you know you're left with a spectrum of
hazards right from my perspective i
don't want to take tylenol because of
the liver damage but i prefer to take
tylenol over advil for example because
i'm in a much better position to
tolerate uh liver damage um since i'm
not a heavy drinker my liver is in good
shape um but heart damage you know
it's hard to tell how much it will
actually reduce lifespan but it very
plausibly will and for children for
instance uh who can't take aspirin
because of what is it ray's syndrome or
something syndrome um
uh you know for those hopefully very
rare occasions when pain relief is
called for
uh tylenol is a is a reasonable
reasonable approach yeah yeah
okay uh next question same sort of topic
uh could an owl deliver mail
thank you for your clarity and insights
each week
um could an owl deliver
mail
um
i'd certainly like to know that owl i
would i would very much like to be in
the company of that owl and hang out
maybe have some drinks but no tylenol
with that owl if you're shipping rodents
i wouldn't recommend it that's probably
true it's like when the chewy box comes
to the door and it gets dragged inside
and then we leave and leave the fork or
never
three carnivorous and we now live with
alone
inside with a
well-wrapped box of cat food or dog food
not smart no it's not nice either
um
yeah i don't know i i would not i would
not bet on owls being a highly effective
avian form of
male delivery yeah i would think
patients would be a better choice yeah
given that they have a
history of collaboration with humans in
this regard yeah i mean
let's put it this way if you're actually
also put up with it
if you're starting a business and you're
thinking of an exploratory project i
would say start with email
owls sending email delivering email i
see
i don't know i'm not sure what the
question means are you sure you read it
correctly yeah no i mean i think it's a
reference to harry potter right all
right yeah and you know i think um the
owl is
owls
i'm not an expert on owls at all but all
the species i've thought about are just
there it's a glorious clade and i i
believe owl is monophyletic yeah it's a
single plate of um like nocturnal
except for the pygmy owl
really it's a different thing it's a
different evolution no no it's an owl
but it's the iron
okay yes it's a single clade
of of uh
basically raptory things um that does
not share a history with um hawks or
eagles or vultures and then vultures are
two different things too new worldview
full uh new world vultures and old world
vultures so old world vultures are
storks i think
or is that new world vultures wow do i
not know yeah no it's winter
it's one of the vulture clades that are
actually most closely related to storks
um so now we're far-field from owls but
uh right owls i i think i think rowling
put owls in there because it makes an
amazing sort of romantic vision but no i
don't think that'd actually be very good
all right i mean i wonder if the person
if this is a reference to harry potter
is the person aware that harry potter
has been exposed as fake news
i probably not well now you know yep
yep
okay
um
there are links and it's very hard for
me to click on links unfortunately
um
what is the evidence that masks work
why aren't n95 masks for the general
population
i think there's a word missing here why
aren't 95 mass for the general
population recommended if the standard
masks aren't fully effective
i will say we were
early
on
recommending masks
and
the evidence
as one attempts to sort it out is less
and less compelling
that masks are
effective why they are not effective or
whether they are effective and it's
difficult to demonstrate
is a little bit unclear but i will say a
number of people have looked into this
question um carefully and it is
it is difficult to demonstrate their
effectiveness so that raises questions
about
um
you know maybe it makes sense
to
uh mandate them in circumstances where
they are most likely to be effective
but there are also cases in which
we seem to be recommending them
for reasons that
are more easily explained as a desire to
drive people towards compliance
with
official dictates rather than because
there's a good medical reason for it and
again i would just point out in our
defense we were early on masks we were
wearing masks before other people were
before they were recommended and so this
is a change in position based on the
fact that unfortunately the evidence
just doesn't support their
their effectiveness now and 95 masks are
likely to be more effective actually
there's another question i don't
remember if this is from the same person
but it's highly relevant here the mask
effective percentage numbers on the cdc
slides question was that n95 how
protective are the n95s thanks i don't
know like i this is this is the problem
with you know even when we are allowed
in briefly to see the official
presentation so often the relevant
information is missing yeah
i don't know
yeah but i i thought you were continuing
to go no i'm my point is just look it
would be great if masks were highly
effective maybe they're more effective
than
we are capable of easily demonstrating
for some reason though the more people
look for their effectiveness and don't
find it the less likely that is there
are distinctions between types of masks
there are also distinctions
um
you know
so the
[Music]
distinction between efficacy and
effectiveness is significant here um it
is certainly true that some masks are
easier to wear than others and therefore
to the extent that there's any efficacy
at all a mask that you're liable to have
with you liable to be able to put on
quickly
might be more positive even if uh under
controlled conditions it's less
effective but exactly i mean i saw a guy
today with a long beard who had a mask
on and
you know i was like okay you're being
forced to wear this mask but um
you know he didn't look happy to have it
on but you know how effective is it at
you can't get it under your under your
chin if it's you know it's blocked by
your beard and like okay we need
if they're effective at all we need
masks that work for various um
faces and and and facial hairs yep and
you know really what we need is a
scientific system that is capable of
addressing questions without
anybody
putting their thumb on the scale so that
we could have good information on what
works and you know no amount of wanting
masks to work is going to change whether
they are or aren't effective right so
what we need to know i mean look you
know at the beginning of this think back
to when we thought surfaces were going
to be a
source of transmission
and the fact is it radically changed our
behavior and then i think we've
forgotten to be grateful that that
didn't turn out to be a major mode of
transmission and then we could uh forego
a lot of the
you know feeling paranoid about every
surface around you
um you know and so the point is that was
information and it upgraded our
well-being the information that the
outdoor environment was safe upgraded
our well-being and
the problem is it's getting hard to
trust the information because frankly
something you know something
either was completely inept or wanted us
to be afraid of the outside even though
it wasn't dangerous at the beginning of
this yep and uh and we're not in a good
position to know i will say so you said
you know we forgot we've forgotten to be
grateful uh for not having to be so
careful about services now um but one
you know one good thing that emerged
from that
uh was we got a bunch of little pump
bottles little spray bottles
that we filled with mostly basically
190 proof alcohol
and just a little bit of um
i'm putting in like palo santo now but
it could be you know any essential oil
just so it doesn't smell like alcohol
uh and um having you know i have one in
my purse i have one in my backpack i
have we have them in the car in the
truck uh and when you get for instance
if you get back into the car
um from whatever you've been doing just
spray your hands right and you know just
being able to immediately clean your
hands because we do touch our faces and
that that you know
there are other things in the universe
besides starskovy too right right that
do transmit that way and being able as
soon as you return to a place that is
your own immediately clean your hands so
you don't have to worry about the toilet
that you flushed or the doorknob that
you turned or the hand that you shook
is
is really useful and
you know that's different than
spraying yourself down with these
antibacterial
products why because the antibacterial
products
are a selective force to create ana
bacterial resistance yep right and
a a generic um
not generic a generalized
broad spectrum thing like alcohol which
just tends to think kill things on
contact um is not going to provide the
same selective force
so um that you can obviously generalize
that that analysis to other things as
well but in general if you're trying to
kill something you'd rather go after it
with something as broad as possible that
it can't evade and thus create a
selective force for it to become ever
more targeted and ever more dangerous
yep absolutely it's a lesson we will at
some point at some point learn
we as a society yeah the idea that you
know you can think you're about to
outwit something evolutionarily and if
you start pushing it around in the wrong
way it will prove you wrong but that
there are actually approaches that don't
have this problem and actually you know
it's probably not something we need to
go into here but there is a question
about whether or not alcohol will select
for
let's say extremophiles among
bacteria or viruses
but
my guess would be even if it does
what happens is it's part of a trade-off
and those extremophiles now have other
fragilities right they are
not favored when in the absence of
alcohol which is the majority of the
landscape and so they will quickly
evolve back to yeah it'll be different
for viruses it's like temperature um
you're elevating your temperature
which we call fever as a way to evade
some pathogens that have narrow
tolerances or um
going well outside the um the ph bounds
of the normal tolerances either highly
basic or highly acidic uh will tend to
work and be a more permanent solution
than having a very narrowly targeted uh
thing that goes after you know one
particular aspect of the organism you're
aiming for right in fact it's a big part
of why the stomach is so acidic is that
um things that are evolved for a much
less acidic environment don't do well
there and so it basically sterilizes uh
as it digests yeah
let's do how long have we been at it sec
and how exactly so okay i've got um
four more questions chosen um of course
lots more that we haven't gotten to but
um oh wait here's one that i wasn't
gonna get to thank you that corrective
lens you read heather got me in the
feelers
we're in new zealand lockdown
yeah um okay so i've got four questions
here new zealand lockdown
summer is coming
yeah
yeah
summer is coming it must feel a long way
off though
uh because they've you know they've
still got three more weeks of winter yet
and then spring and spring is coming
spring's pretty good though i mean you
got to admit
yeah a few things better than spring
i like summer summer's great but after
winter spring ah
really well said thank you um does our
long evolutionary history as
hunter-gatherers speak to the necessity
of meat in our diet and therefore debunk
veganism
um
debunk is not the right word that's
right uh let's put it this way
veganism
is
difficult to do to do well right it's
very impossible it's very easy to be
malnourished that way yeah um especially
raw food vegans and we i mean we
actually address this specifically in
the book and maybe even in the section
that we read
but you know raw uncooked food it's
harder for your body to extract what it
needs from it and then
and then entirely non-animal based food
doesn't have as much of some of the
things that your body needs yep
um so i mean i think we've more or less
gotten there it's it it can be done it's
a stretch
meat solves a lot of problems uh
properly cooked meat
solves problems you know it liberates a
lot of a lot of nutrition and you know
we don't have you know if
it would debunk veganism if veganism
were the hypothesis that we are involved
to be vegan right like all you have to
do really is look at our gut morphology
our gut morphology and our teeth you can
look at either of those things and you
see that we are not um dedicated grazers
or folivores um or even you know
including frugivores like you know we
have guts that look like an intermediate
between those of dedicated carnivores
and those of dedicated herbivores and
the fact is we you know we're involved
to do both
and the same thing with the teeth we've
got both um sort of plant plant sharing
teeth and meat grinding teeth or maybe
shearing and grinding belong in the
other words there i don't know but
we've got we've got canines that pierce
and uh
and molars that grind and
uh yep and
no
sagittal crest
uh so we have reduced musculature we
have all sorts of modifications that
speak to a well but the surgical crests
can go both ways um because gorillas
have a big sagittal crest as do hyenas
yeah and gorillas are dedicated
folivores and hyenas are dedicated
carnivores so you know you want a big
masseter which is what the sagittal
crust attaches to if you're doing a lot
of chewing of leaves or if you're doing
a lot of ripping of meat off whatever
you're doing that requires the exertion
of a lot of force yeah so that that that
one can go either way
um
but yeah dentition and gut morphology
and you know there's there's a lot more
besides that but those are two easy ones
to point to yeah yeah
um
this may be two questions i can't tell
yet
new political party based on integrity
absence
of capture
you may have to help me read this one um
the second part of the question which
reads like a question is does sociopathy
or psychopathies roll into turret and
totalitarianism need to be understood
the first part of the question i'm not
sure i understand i think it i think
there may be it may be too compressed
for me to be making sense of it okay
um i would say i don't think we've got
sociopathy and psychopathy right for one
thing i don't think we have a clean
distinction between them and so we sort
of take psychopathy as extreme
sociopathy
um and i mean that is the description
and some i mean i don't think it's a
book in this room but i think that has
been
that has been a description by some
clinicians yep
um i would just say
i think
those who write
fiction that is compelling understand
some things about
sociopathy that we
at the level of our analysis do not yet
accept right which is
that
sociopathy when we say someone is a
sociopath we mean that they are an
obligate sociopath and that facultative
sociopathy is actually extremely common
obligate sociopathy is common enough but
much less common and psychopathy is some
malignant form or maybe it's
a form that is reserved it could be a
lineage level adaptation reserved for
very extreme circumstances in other
words do you
need brutal killers uh in your
military force you know obviously every
soldier doesn't need to be a psychopath
but
is there a value to having them
available for
some operations or something like that
but anyway the the the argument i've
made before is
the problem with sociopathy is that it
is
directed arbitrarily in our system and
that ancestrally it would have been
directed you know that a person you know
a person behaves
sociopathically on a battlefield you're
shooting at somebody you don't know
hoping to kill them right
that's arguably sociopathic and the
point is it doesn't mean you don't come
home and you know love your family and
and your friends and
and all of that and so we don't
we don't properly make eye contact with
the fact that we've sent somebody to do
a job that requires them to be
sociopathic in the context of that job
so
i'm not sure where that leaves us but
but basically i don't think we've got
the taxonomy right which means it's very
hard to take the taxonomy we have and
properly apply it because
we are upended by
phenomena that we all understand like
the mob boss who
is thoroughly devoted to his family and
orders
you know murders as if it's just a fact
of life
yep
okay penultimate question
do you have any updates on when you'll
publish info about your effective volume
model or can you point me to some
sources thank you so much so this with
regard to um you specifically said
effective volume model i will say before
you answer um that there
that again this this hospital should let
the outside in piece that i posted on my
substance has you know cites some of the
literature on precisely how larger
volume rooms are associated with better
outcomes specifically with regard to
respiratory uh infections yeah so
that's from you know
most of that research i think is decades
old yeah i don't think we have any uh
ability to do the work to public i mean
i guess we could publish the model but
we don't have the ability to test the
model but i think we have learned a
great deal
in the context of kovid about
basically the effective volume model
says that if you take if you measure a
space
right that space will saturate with uh
aerosolized cobit at some rate and
probably different variants will cause
it to saturate at different rates
that same room becomes effectively
larger if you open a window it becomes
effectively larger than that if you open
two windows on two different walls and
you get cross flow it becomes even
larger if you have a fan on the ceiling
right yeah um so
sorry um zach if you just want to put on
my screen for a moment um this again
from this uh hospital she left the
outside in the substance post
i have here
reference to this 2007 study out of peru
which was comparing
basically hospital rooms that were older
to those i think this is the one
natural ventilation for the prevention
of airborne contagion which again it's
not using the same language you were
using but they specifically are looking
at at some of this so you can go there
to find some of what you're looking for
but i think the thing is you know it is
a guideline but it's an you know it's an
intuitive
guideline yeah right um
you can look at the volume of a room
without measuring anything you can
figure out you know
there's a restaurant that we have
been to a number of times that has an
outdoor space that we prefer it's got an
indoor space but one of the walls of the
indoor space is
like a garage door that opens up which
effectively increases the volume of the
entire building and it especially
increases the volume of the portion of
the building right next to that wall
yeah presumably in the winter that door
isn't open but we've been seated inside
at least once during the summer when it
was just all full outside which again is
our preference but that door was open
which meant that this is you know this
is not an enclosed space in the same way
it would be if there was just a door
that was occasionally open when people
came and went right and it's somewhere
intermediate between an outdoor you know
when we talk about it and that space
actually also happens to have very it's
got like loft style seating ceilings
um so you know it's really quite the
opposite of like an intimate little
french bistro or something which you
know there are moments when you might
want that when it gives a sense of of
community even among the strangers with
whom you're sitting almost cheek to gel
but that sitting cheek to jowl with
strangers and you know being able to
overhear them that comes with potential
respiratory costs for sure yeah
absolutely and then you know there are
other questions about um how quickly
people are passing through a space
how long they spend there right um so
anyway uh yeah but no intent to publish
an explicit model but basically as an
intuitive guide it's not that hard to
figure out you know
what works in the positive direction
what works in a negative direction and
you know what the magnitudes might be
like yeah and that um that piece that i
showed is
available publicly and actually i think
i just i just posted the audio version
of it which um the audio transcripts of
my substance pieces are
only for paying subscribers but i was
actually thinking already that i would
make that one publicly available because
i think it is really
so relevant uh right now that sort of
just getting in the habit of thinking in
terms of like what are the values of
being outside what are the values of
being in larger rooms and so that is
exactly what that piece explores yep and
i'm trying not to lean too heavily on
the fact that
the season that shall not be named is
coming thank you for not relying too
heavily on yes i'm not relying too
heavily on that but i would point out
that whether or not that season is named
it is coming and it is going to have all
kinds of effects on what kinds of
volumes these spaces we are going to be
in will have and therefore
um let's not kid ourselves and let's get
good at this and
make it better than it might otherwise
be yeah
okay final question for today
do you think it would be a good idea to
relocate to a rural less populated area
if authoritarian measures increase
domestically or even to a different
country
yes
i mean you know it's it's it's built
into your question yeah um you know we
were literally just talking about this
you've got to think you got to think
about
the parameters right somehow
we don't know what authoritarianism will
look like it you know it could be
surgical authoritarianism that uh yes
limits freedoms greatly but leaves us
more or less intact it could be that the
authoritarianism itself causes a
breakdown in social order as a certain
fraction of the population refuses to
accept it
so anyway in thinking about where you
might go think about
what various scenarios might look like
and how robust
uh such a thing might be i would say
among the things that you should think
very carefully about
is how difficult will it be to
generate a meaningful community where
you're headed right especially if you're
coming in as an outsider who doesn't
know anybody
it's very important that
if the outside world stops making sense
that the people immediately around you
make as much sense as possible and uh
it's you know it's not it shouldn't be a
second thought
or an afterthought yeah
very good
um well i think i think that brings us
to the end
of the q a for today of q a number 94 so
um
in conclusion we will say
as we always do encourage you to join
our one of both of our patreons tomorrow
is the private q a on my patreon at 11
am pacific
which is intimate enough that we
actually end up being able to engage
with the chat
i believe that means that next weekend
um
will be your conversations on your
patreon
uh you can ask quest logistical
questions uh at darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com
get things like goliath shirts at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
and consider you know share this if you
like it like it if you like it subscribe
to the channels if you like it uh there
are four of them two on youtube two on
odyssey this one that you're watching
brett weinstein's my channel and then
darkhorse podcast clips
uh which are amazing clip sky takes
things each week and uh
and shortens them and they're you know
more easily digestible because they
don't last for over an hour and so also
if there's anything uh from today that
you thought was particularly clip worthy
you can go ahead and send that
suggestion to
darkcoursemoderator gmail.com or leave
it as a comment um and he usually sees
those although no guarantees we tend to
get a lot of comments
anything else to say before somebody
send haircuts
all right i'll go get a haircut i'll
take care of i'm sorry that was uh i was
hoping somebody would send one but um
before we see you next week i think it
is likely that both of us may have
gotten haircuts
um
in the meantime be good to the ones you
love
and eat good food and get outside be
well everybody
[Music]
you